first on cbs this morning michael
jackson's family they are speaking out
about sexual abuse allegations against a
singer in an explosive new hbo
documentary
in leaving neverland wade robson and
james safetruck claim
jackson abused him for years when they
were young children the documentary
premieres this weekend
jackson has always denied any
inappropriate behavior with children
safechuck and robson both sued the
jackson estate but their lawsuits were
dismissed
because of the statute of limitations
they are now appealing that
the jackson family insists those claims
are lies
we spoke to michael jackson's nephew taj
and brothers jackie
marlon and tito i take this interview
very very seriously because it is very
disturbing to me and that's why i did
want to talk to
this child psychologist who's an expert
she said
it is extremely rare for teenage boys to
make false claims of inappropriate
sexual conduct against a man in
particular unless you're michael jackson
wade robson met michael jackson when he
was five
james safe chuck filmed a commercial
with jackson just before he turned nine
both say that for years the pop icon
invited them to his homes
and molested them accusations the
jackson family
vehemently denies one thing that struck
me that wade said
he calls michael jackson one of the most
kindest
gentle loving caring people person he
knows
who helped him creatively but also
sexually abused him from the ages of 7
to 14.
do any of you think that both can be
true michael helped him in
in what he wanted to do and with videos
and music from the
from that side of things but if
neverland was so horrifying for him and
why would you keep going back none of us
in this room were there
at the time that these allegations were
made so how can you say what they're
saying
are lies no we weren't there and nobody
was there but
the facts are a public record i mean
would he testify under over all the
different things that he said
those are the facts in the past both men
have said that jackson
never harmed them in 1993 safechuck gave
a statement to police
for a molestation case involving another
boy
no criminal charges were filed
in 2005 when jackson faced criminal
charges
robson took the stand his testimony is
often credited with helping jackson win
in court
wade and james both say wade in
particular has admitted yes i lied on
the stand
yes i lied under oath yes i lied to my
parents
yes i lied to everyone i cared about
because
i wanted to protect michael he did not
want to be the one
in his words that harm michael jackson
do you not believe him when he says that
i do not believe him when he said that
because we know our brother michael
wouldn't do anything like that
and then he waits until after the
passing of michael
ten years later to come out and state
this and he's they're still in court
with
with their estate suing them for
hundreds of millions of dollars
michael's not here to defend himself so
you think the only reason they're doing
it is because michael is no longer here
and you you don't buy that they they
wanted to protect them and that's why i
don't know
no wait's never protected anyone in his
life does the whole family feel this way
i've seen the comments from the brothers
but i haven't heard anything from your
sisters
of course i think there's a fear as well
to put more energy to it and more
eyeballs to it i think that's why
my janet hasn't said anything because
she doesn't want to make it any bigger
why do you think they're coming forward
now money you think it's all about money
it's all about money it's always been
about money i hate to say it when it's a
when it's my uncle it's almost like they
see a blank check
in there and because they've been taken
care of their whole life
and and i think that's the problem these
people are felt
that they're owed something you know
instead of working for something
they blame everything on my uncle some
would say there's a lot at stake
financially for the jackson family as
well no uh we get we don't get anything
from this thing emotionally
emotionally though the jacksons haven't
seen the documentary
and say they will never watch it they
take issue with filmmaker dan reed
who they say never reached out to the
family for their side of the story
so he took what they were saying face
value as
as to be true but he trusted them
but which is nothing wrong with that but
you must verify because when you start
throwing allegations out about someone
then you got to go back and go wait a
minute let me make sure i'm telling the
right thing
make sure they're not selling me a bunch
of goods which which they were
what do you want to say about your
brother as this documentary is about to
hit the country i want them to
understand and know
that uh this documentary
is not telling the truth uh there there
has not been
not one piece of evidence that
corroborates their story
uh and they're not interested in doing
that some would say though guys it's
hard for you to sit here and say the
documentary isn't telling the truth when
you haven't seen the documentary
shouldn't you
see the documentary i don't care he said
no because i know my brother i don't
have to say that documentary
i know michael i'm the oldest brother i
know my brother
i know what he stood for what he was all
about bringing the world together
making kids happy and he was never in
your opinion abusive to children never
never never inappropriate with children
never a sexual way
the people that really know him they
know the truth too
yeah they are very adamant as you see
they said that over and over and over
again and
even asked different ways about michael
they all go back to we know him
the world doesn't know him the way we
know him and he would never ever hurt a
child which is what michael jackson
used to say all the time and look i
understand as a family
they want to defend and protect him but
one thing that stood out to me watching
the documentary is how alone michael
jackson seemed right you didn't see the
family around him in fact he viewed
these boys
as family so that that doesn't
necessarily work
with what they're saying he had a very
complicated relationship with his family
and
and
when you see the documentary you will
see he felt very close to strangers
who you would think didn't know him as
well as his family did it's a very
interesting dynamic
all the way around but they are very
adamant about this michael jackson did
not do this this is about money and
their brother
is not here to defend himself